billy is a man of many trades
he's from canada and he's a painter all
right let me try i emailed billy for a
painting that i wanted to have made for
mike and we befriended each other and
started dancing together on tick-tock
[Music]
but billy is not your typical dancer he
used to be in the 80s a male stripper
and his title was the original thieve of
hearts
and boy does he still have the moves
and the looks
that's all i can do
they look at the smile on your face
billy still is in canada so we haven't
met each other yet but we talk all the
time that's what you do to people billy
[Music]
with michael being so distant to me and
making me feel like he's using me as an
opportunity to come to the u.s i've had
to find support
in new people billy makes time for me
and he listens to me
becoming friends with you has made my
outlook look different in life like
you're just an amazing man period
i appreciate that
i want to ask you something
it's kind of awkward because i don't
know how you feel about this
i feel like we haven't met what do you
think about
me coming to canada
i would love to see you come to canada
really
yeah i love it
billy i just have one concern about
coming to canada
what's that
with all them dance moves that you have
i'm gonna run out of
mean
dollar
bills
oh
i better go take a loan out
[Music]
you